[Music]
a teenager is behind bars after police
say he was responsible for firing
multiple shots during a drive-by
shooting thanks for joining us at five
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis
it happened earlier this month in a
Centennial Hills neighborhood near
Durango in the 95 some of those bullets
hitting two teens critically injuring
one our eight news now investigators
breaking news of this arrest earlier
this morning 8 news now reporter
Victoria Saha joining us from the
Regional Justice Center where the teen
appeared in front of a judge this
afternoon
yeah a 17 year old Hakeem Collette was
arrested this morning after that
shooting that occurred nearly two weeks
ago today in court he didn't really have
much to say as prosecutors revealed this
wasn't his first time getting in trouble
the 17 year old was on probation for
stealing a car when he pulled the
trigger in a drive-by shooting that
shooting occurring in the middle of the
afternoon just as kids were coming home
from school and playing outside in court
it was revealed to Colette buyer 12
times those bullets pierced a nearby car
and hit a 12 year old girl and a 14 year
old boy that 14 year old boy was shot
five times and was critically injured
Colette remaining Behind Bars tonight as
the judge did not release him on bail
Colette will be back in court on
Wednesday the mother of that 14 year old
boy who was shot was actually in court
as well she tells me she's relieved that
there's been an arrest but she's still
questioning why this happened Victoria
Saha 8 News Now